I had known about this story
for decades.
The disaster of 1871
was one of the the things
that basically ended Yankee
whaling in the in the early 20th century,
because it was such a devastating loss.
What was still there,
if anything, was still
there, was a question
that needed to be answered.
I was the mission coordinator.
Once we got there, it was deeply personal.
We were going out we were
going to essentially develop
a map of the seabed between Point
Franklin and Wainwright.
I remember sitting on the after
deck of the vessel
we were on and thinking to myself,
you know,
this is the same place
where the whalers tucked in.
They were here and now we're here.
And and that was a very
powerful experience for me.
One of the first things
we did was to scan using sonar,
with sonar
you're basically bouncing
sound waves off the seabed
and building a picture
from the returning signal.
What you're looking for are straight
lines, which are rare in nature.
What's it look like on the screen?
Suddenly you see these straight lines
and then more horizontal figures
blocks and like that.
That looks interesting.
That could be a piece of a shipwreck.
The sonar picked up six features
that appeared to be manmade.
So the sonar can be a bit misleading.
Is it a provocatively
shaped group of rocks
or is that the outline of a hull?
That's when you need to put eyes on.
Diving was not an option.
You're literally in water
that's just above freezing.
You get into that water and, it hurts.
To avoid diving,
we created a drop camera system
that can be lowered to the seabed.
We started to drag the drop camera
around, trying to get a better view of
what was there.
See that? What is that?
Suddenly this structure appeared.
It was a mass of heavy wood.
You could see sections of the hull
that were there indicating
some of that structure had survived.
You had the broken ends
of the ribs of the frames
that have been gnawed by the ice
but is covered in marine growth.
You had some stone ballast as well
that helped stabilize that ship
when it was afloat.
You go, okay,
we've got a shipwreck.
Pieces of copper
sheathing were visible on sections
of planking next to the 70 foot long hull.
It was clear evidence
that what we were looking at
was a vessel that at least been built
in the 19th century.
We now knew a shipwreck
could survive underwater from the North
Alaskan coast.